I get striked,
I've heard depressed people who stopped
antidepressants 70 never helped in the
first place.
What do you say to that,
Mr. Peterson?
Hey,
that,
that's certainly possible.
Um,
antidepressants don't
necessarily work for everyone.
My personal opinion is
that antidepressants work
quite well for many people
whose lives are in decent order.
So they have friends,
they have family that loved them,
they have a career,
they're educated approximately to
the level of their intelligence.
They have things to look forward to,
but for some reason their
mood is extremely distorted.
M and,
and negative.
And I've seen antidepressants have
miraculous effects on people like that.
I think they're less likely to work
when people have a plethora of life
problems,
which isn't exactly
the same thing as being
depressed.
You know,
like you've been having a terrible
life is not the same thing as being
depressed.
Although the two can overlap.
And it isn't obvious
to me that people who,
you know,
maybe they have a drinking problem
or a drug abuse problem and they're
unemployed and they have a pathological
family and their friends aren't good for
them.
And,
um,
you know,
they,
they have a string of failures behind
them and they don't have much to look
forward to in the future and all that.
It's,
it's a lot for an antidepressant overcome.
But under those circumstances,
maybe the antidepressants can help stave
off feelings of like suicidal feelings
and that sort of thing.
But antidepressants
don't work for everyone,
but some people they work really well for.
And if you're depressed,
they're definitely worth a try.
You know,
in a month if they're going to work.
Also,
there are a variety of different kinds
of antidepressants and you have to figure
up dose and you have to figure out when
you should take them during the day and
you,
and you have to figure out tight.
So they're,
they're not a cure or they're a tool
for helping control negative emotion and
they can be very effective.
So,
but that doesn't mean that there
aren't people that they didn't help.
So that's what I would say about that.